>> Donald Trump says he won't
drop out of the race for the
Republican nomination even if
he were to be indicted.
Former president is involved in
multiple federal and state
investigations --
prosecutors are looking into
his efforts to overturn his
2020 election loss, and the --
January 6th attack on the
capital, as well as trump's
handling of classified
documents.
After he left office.
And joining me now is trump's
former lawyer and fixer,
Michael Cohen.
He's the author of revenge, how
Donald Trump weaponize the U.S.
Department of justice against
his critics and host of the mea
culpa podcast.
Michael, great to see you.
I mean, I guess there is really
no surprise here that trump is
insisting in indictment will
not stop him from running.
I suppose, with his base, it
will be like more catnip.
>> Yeah.
That is the Donald Trump fake
tough guy talk, whereby I don't
care what anybody thinks that
they will do to me, you can
indict me, you will come after
me, it won't sway me and it
won't prevent me from running.
Unfortunately for Donald, what
he doesn't seem to understand
or maybe he does, it is just
not trying to show it is that
--
lou'tis chains, one of our
unsinkable attorney general is
continuing and I believe they
have --
at the end of this month, so
despite whatever he thinks he
is going to be involved in that
litigation, on top of that is
--
decides to indict and move
forward, he will be involved in
that litigation as well,
whether or not there are --
truth social tough guy.
On top of that, you have the
January 6th hearings that you
have, so many other litigations
that are now pending against
him, there is absolutely
nothing but he could do about
it, nothing.
Yeah, let me ask you that just
since you brought it up, you
have been speaking with the
Manhattan d.a.'s office in the
investigation of the payments
saying that they're covering up
trump's alleged affair with
stormy Daniels, how close do
you think that cases from some
kind of revolution, maybe an
indictment, you think that is
soon?
>> Yeah.
So I don't want to acknowledge
or disagree with your statement
about what the district
attorney is specifically
looking at, obviously everybody
knows about the hush money
payment, but I don't suspect
that that is the only thing
they are looking at.
I am going back again for
additional prep, 4 grand jury
prep and I am very confident,
and I suspect that Alvin Gregg
and his really fine team of
prosecutors believe that there
is enough with which to charge
Donald Trump.
Again, that is Alvin Gregg's
decision.
I think that they finally see
what --
Kerrigan saw about earlier go.
Now it is Alvin Bragg's turn.
--
moving very quickly over there.
Stay tuned is right.
>> All right.
And, I didn't need to put
honest pop there, and I want to
talk about C pack because you
used to go with trump to see
pack, how surprising was it to
see him winning that straw --
all these investigations into
his actions before, during and
after his presidency?
Did you think that he would be
at this point right now?
>> By the way, it is like going
to a bingo parlor, you are the
only one there and hey, I won
bingo.
He is the only one that is
there.
I mean, other than Nikki Haley,
who else is announcing?
See pack right now is not the C
pack of before when actually I
saw you there and so many other
people and that place was
packed with wall-to-wall people
and if you see Donald speech
that was their, 60% of the room
as completely void.
There is empty chairs,
everywhere.
When I was there with him, it
was standing room only.
Now all of a sudden you are
playing to probably 45% of what
the general crowd is.
This entire seed pack like
match slap, like big bossy in
the rest of the crew, it is
meaningless.
It doesn't tell you anything
and the fact again that he won
the stronghold again is, it is,
he is the only guy in the bingo
parlor in many ways.
It doesn't mean anything.
>> Got it.
Last time, the speechless night
Michael, I mean you heard some
of this rhetoric before but it
does seem to be ratcheting up,
he is doubling himself the
candidate of retribution --
what does that say to you?
>> It says the gym, you and I
could have a lot of problems,
if in fact this lunatic becomes
president because I am still
maintaining, I don't even think
that Donald is going to get the
nomination.
I know everybody says no, he
has such a strong hold over
like 25% of the Republican
party and what we are seeing
right now is Donald Trump's
popularity, believe it or not,
decreasing on a steady basis.
And it is more of these
indictments, more of these
charges continue to be mounted
against him, and he starts to
really feel the pressure of
what is called accountability.
I don't believe that Donald is
going to be the nominee and I
think that you are going to see
somebody new come out of the
woodwork and I think that is
who we are going to see a lot
of support coming for.
Right now, it is just Donald.
>> Quick follow-up though on
that Michael, that is, we saw
one potential --
former governor of Maryland
saying he is not going to run.
It does look as though this is
going to be a smaller field
than we have seen in years
past.
It, if you look at what Nikki
Haley and Mike pump hail were
doing at CPAC, not calling him
out by name and tiptoeing
around him, where the
candidates who will go out and
confront him face to face?
It is just not happening at
this point.
Doesn't that make it easier for
him to win the nomination?
>> To the contrary.
If fewer people are there in
that race, the better the
chances are that that
individual wins the specific
state.
The more people that are in,
the more it gets divided.
It is a winner take all.
The thing with Larry hogan, I
bet most of you viewers say,
who is Larry hogan?
Most of them have no idea who
he has.
He has no name recognition.
Week till you see down the road,
as they get closer to the
nomination process, you will
start to see better names,
better recognize people start
to enter the race.
And again, I still feel very
confident that all of these
indictment charges, Donald will
definitely want to be the
nominee because he will then
make the claim that you can't
come after him, his
presidential candidate despite
the fact that that doesn't
exonerate him or prevent the
litigation from continuing.
>> All right.
You have a point there, we will
be talking about that I'm sure